E BEACH.F SHARK TACKG .OMESE A E
A  BBY AHI OF FIRE
ISLAND IN NEW YORK LEA
WIE GASH OIGHT THERE.
AM COMD
ASK E T AS THEY P FOR THE 34th I
YEAR, THAT'S RIGHT, 34thEAR OF
THEIR EVERULAR SHARK WEEK.
HERE'S A PREVIEW.
>> THERE.
>> THEY'RE STAYING DEEP, AND
THEY'RE COMING UD HITTING.
I'VE ALREADY HAD TWO
THAT HAVE BEEN PRETTY
LIFIBERATE.HE GETTING
WHAT WAS THAT?HAT
YEAH, IT WAS.P
]
NOTIEWERS,
JOOWGENDARSHARWEE, BUTLI
FILMMAKEERU WILL SEE ON DISCOVEH
YOWHEN N SOMAR
AD THAIFYING
U MEN
THAT, ER LIKE THAT, 'VEERN ANYTL
S AT YOUE THATNG TW JIMMY,
HAG MING TFAERE, HEVES
MOUTH LIKE AE D 'S GU , RIU THEA
WATCH, EVE, THE AY IT ST HEART
COMPLETELY HELPLESS.
ERNG WE
HELP HIM.
US>> AND THAT CONTAINER THATE'SA
EN? WAS THIS SHA JUS,  HT
>> YEAH, YOU KNOW, TRUTH B, GRSH
ANY CAGE THAT WE PUT
IN THE
SOMETHG  T REALLY MATTER WE AL
TH ITS, ITBACK
AYWE SAW A LOT OSH PARTICULAR CD
AND
THEY WOULD BACK AWAYTHIS ONEN P.
AND  CAMH A STANCEAT HE PRAB DIH
E E THINGS Y H NTIC, VERY,  ANDE
LI T HOE SEENG
ENT IT'S STILL AAMAZING SEQUENC
ABSHARKS JUST FROM WCH>>F YOU'R
FOBEVE FORCEHEE  CALO OWA
GREAT WHITE SHARK BREACHTHTHIS M
LET'S WATCH.
THIS TIM
INVERTOCKE
ITS TARGETIKA FIGHTE MEAN,HA WI.
ATE WH
SOMETHING HANI CREATT SIZE
EARE'S NG MORECTACULAIN
FILM THIS AN SERIE B T
THAT JAWS.N ON T AIR SINCE AND
G THESE SHARY T IT'S AN AMAZING
INED4K, AND THE RE HAV
E
WHEN THE SHARK OPENS IOU
LY COUNT
IN HISTHOW GOOD TH
AND OF COURSE IN SUPER S
MOTION IJUSTPECTACULAR.H, AIR J.
STORIES TO TELL, BUT PEOPL